well one part of town one night
116 traffic stops yeah the number is big
and so is the problem of illegal
straight racing in the valley
authorities have announced their very
latest efforts to crack down on the
issue and they are seeing results 8 news
now reporter sasha loftis joins us live
from the northwest with more
denise and brian you can see these tire
tracks here left over from drifting and
drag racing just a few weeks ago those
we spoke with in this area say they're
glad something is being done to stop
things like this from happening again
it was just out of control chaos really
paul caratini describes this startling
scene
happening in his neighborhood it's just
an accident waiting to happen dozens
gathered racing and drifting near gowen
and grand canyon on new year's eve
unfortunately situations like this are
all too common across the northwest
valley eight news now has spoken to many
others who say they're fed up and want
to see something done reckless driving
going on in our neighborhood for the
past two and a half years these
individuals were doing these 360s and
fast it was so fast they could have lost
control at any time on sunday north las
vegas police and metro police joined
efforts to crack down on reckless
driving and illegal street racing 19
officers made
116 traffic stops on roads notorious for
complaints they issued 11 citations for
reckless driving and 68 for speeding
they also caught four drag racers in the
act i think this is a great start
caratini says he's thrilled to see
action being taken and hopes this will
deter others from turning his backyard
into a dangerous drag strip glad that
they did something about it
metro has reported several other street
racing crackdowns over the last few
months they ticketed 41 people and
arrested 19 others on january 3 just a
few weeks ago for racing speeding and
what they call trick driving reporting
live in the northwest valley tonight
sasha loftis live local now